un día de reivindicaciones globales
desde Argentina Colombia miles de
latinoamericanos salieron a las calles
en el Día Internacional del trabajo los
más recientes mandatarios y
izquierdistas lanzaron mensajes de
movilización social reforma salariales y
pensionales con el presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro que presiona al congreso
para que apoye sus polémicas reformas
sociales laboral o la de la salud
pueblos
trabajador en la primera línea de la
lucha por las transformaciones de
Colombia en La Vanguardia del
progresismo de este país
Los invito a estar en la vanguardia de
la historia de Colombia somos los
brasileño Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva con
grego a miles de personas en Sao Paulo
donde confirmó un reajuste del salario
mínimo una de sus promesas de campaña
así como un incremento del sueldo mínimo
para trabajadores jubilados y
pensionistas
hemos instituido una vez más Un aumento
Real del salario mínimo por encima de la
inflación
[Aplausos]
a partir de ahora además de la inflación
el trabajador recibirá el crecimiento
medio del pib
en Venezuela donde el salario mínimo
cayó a 5 dólares por la inflación
cientos de trabajadores salieron a las
calles para exigir mejoras en sus
condiciones laborales mientras el
mandatario Nicolás duro prometió Un
aumento del cesta ticket un mono de
alimentación a 40 dólares y del Bono de
guerra económica al sector de la
educación jubilados públicos y
pensionistas a 20 dólares como adiciones
salariales en Sudamérica la mayoría de
gobiernos son de izquierda pero los
desafíos en derechos para los
trabajadores en especial para las
mujeres y jóvenes siguen siendo amplios
debido en parte a las altas tasas de
informalidad laboral en la región